hoje em dia há conhecimento está
distribuída esta espalhava a e a gente
tem que ligar com esse conhecimento para
ajudar no processo de de inovação mas
não é tão fácil toquei as várias
pesquisas vários estudos aqui mostram
exatamente ss raciocínio que é melhor
dica ao criar várias perspectivas têm
várias disciplinas juntos você vai criar
alguma coisa que ninguém vai chegar
nessa ideia sozinho mas junto você vai
esses estudos que que explicam
exatamente essa assim
na verdade ele estava em outra coisa que
quando você tem várias pessoas de várias
disciplinas várias bacanas para as
culturas diferentes é mais difícil de
criar você vai criar você vai ter
problemas você vai ter conflitos porque
as pessoas têm perspectivas diferentes
né
então a questão pra mim é como a gente
pode ter os benefícios do cal criação
colaboração várias disciplinas sem
creche sem o pânico sem os problemas e
minha idéia é propor um caf o dodô é
inovador é um tipo do professor que é
uma arte pode criar essa inovação que
traz um valor social e esse nome é
elevador h
e você pode ver né h tem tem dois patos
verticais em óleo vegetal e pra mim cada
um representa alguma coisa
desce desce pra fiel dessa pessoa
bom o primeiro
a primeira parte é essa pessoa tem que
ter uma mãe que tem que ser uma
especialista em alguma coisa pode ser
ligado com a as capacidades que elas têm
pode ser ligado com o conhecimento do
mário específico mas elevadores h tem
nesse primeiro empate
elas têm a ela estarão especialistas em
alguma coisa e pode ser por exemplo eu
fiz o projeto do gmail então eu tenho
conhecimento com uma mobilidade urbana
mas pode ser qualquer coisa mas você tem
que desenvolver a uma um profundidade no
mar
ok ok como in the vídeo voz e você tem
que trazer você tem que levar alguma
coisa diferente do que as outras pra
mesa pra criar junto você tem que ter
alguma coisa de diferente do que os
outros
segundo pat
a segunda parte é generalista bom você
tem o pato primeiro peço a vocês é uma
especialista
mas sendo um especialista pode ser
perigoso porque muitas vezes quando você
só tem som só está uma especialista
você tem uma visão assim você você você
tem que ser um pouco mais aberto pra
outras coisas então elevadores h
eles são mais abertos elas têm talvez
eles têm um conhecimento bem profundo
numa área mas elas sabem um pouco eles
conhecem outras coisas também
talvez um elevador h não é um designer
mas ele sabe um ele tem um conhecimento
suficiente para falar com um design em
tauá
ele tem essa capacidade
de falar com outras pessoas a ele tem
outros a capacidades
há também o terceiro pachi
talvez o mais importante é s party
humanista
ele tem que até tinha com pessoas
ele tem que saber é como falar com
pessoas
a elevação vem das necessidades das
então ele tem que é capaz de expressar a
emoção com paixão ele tem que ter é que
a discussão mas isso é fundamental
também é realmente uma pessoa que pode
ter um relacionamento com outras pessoas
que podem ficar perto de outras pessoas
sem esse patch da parte humanista
se você pode ser uma espécie lista você
pode ser aberto a outras ideias também
mas sem esse patch humanista
pra mim ele não é uma inovadora h
elevadores h tem um propósito é pessoal
estão ligados os sabem o que eles querem
criar porque eles querem trazer para o
mundo
isso é fundamental acho que sem esse
propósito você não vá você não vai ser
um elevador
a agá isso acho que não vai haver
madureza gás são as pessoas que
realmente têm um propósito que é o
méxico quer fazer é elevação mas na
organização criando novos produtos novos
produtos criando coisas escritas são o
sinal precisão mas realmente criando um
valor social e vivendo e da shell e
deixando 1
um legado para a sociedade
obrigado gente